what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we're going to be talking
about the X-Men making their way to the
MCU something everybody has been waiting
for for a very long time and something
that Marvel Studios has been teasing
lately specifically Kevin feige and some
producers So today we're going to be
going over everything that we know and
have heard of about the X-Men making
their way to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe also not to mention it looks
like Marvel Studios has been looking at
some older actors who used to be a part
of the fox Marvel franchise to make some
appearances in secret Wars so lots of
exciting things to talk about today also
very exciting news we are doing a big
giveaway until the end of the year we'll
be giving away some Marvel Legends items
of your choice if you win we'll be
giving one away each week until the end
of this year all you have to do to enter
is subscribe to the channel and leave a
comment down below also important
message I will personally comment on
your comment on YouTube tube there have
been some fake giveaways out there they
are scams I apologize for these I've
been working with YouTube to fix them it
will come from my account that says the
cosmic wonder and I will give you my
personal email address I will not
WhatsApp you at all and I will
personally mention the winners in video
so stay on the lookout for that so
recently over the past week or so a lot
of information has been coming out about
Secret Wars I did a big video about it
yesterday so be sure to check that out
if you haven't and it seems like a big
plan for Marvel Studios for Secret Wars
is the X-Men but not exactly how you
would expect it a big part of the secret
Wars news in the X-Men news is that
Marvel Studios wants some of the old
Marvel actors from the fox Universe to
come back for Secret Wars like Hugh
Jackman now Deadpool 3 has showed us
that anything is possible it's been
confirmed already that Hugh Jackman is
returning to play Wolverine for Deadpool
3. so not only is anything possible but
it is actually very likely to happen
according to a report from our buddy
Paul over at heavy spoilers Marvel
Studios is going to bring the previous
Marvel franchises we're talking the old
Fantastic Four the old X-Men the old
Spider-Man all on screen together in
secret Wars he said in a recent video
slash report that's more what they're
aiming for with Avengers Secret Wars as
climax every franchise on screen at the
same time all alongside each other ready
to Duke it out with Kang which is
awesome this is what we all want to see
and it's great that this is probably
what is actually going to happen but
what does that mean for the new X-Men
entering the MCU what about the mutants
that are supposed to be introduced in
Phase 5 and phase six well we have a
pretty good idea of what Marvel
studios's plan is especially after some
producers and Kevin feige has spoken up
himself unfortunately as it turns out
the new X-Men in our Marvel Cinematic
Universe are probably a few years out
most likely debuting after Secret Wars
in a recent interview executive producer
for Marvel Studios Nate Moore discussed
when we could possibly see the X-Men in
the MCU new X-Men characters not old
X-Men characters from the fox universe
and he says they have some plans and
that there's a deep bench however he
does say that the X-Men are most likely
a few years out he specifically said
when talking about new X-Men and the MCU
well Storm's relationship with wakanda
and Publishing is pretty interesting
obviously we might be a few years out
from the X-Men so I'm not sure we're
there yet now this was for an interview
about Black Panther wakanda forever so
it's awesome that they mentioned storm
because she actually marries t'challa in
the comics and of course she's a mutant
and an X-Men so the good news is there
are great plans for the X-Men to appear
in the MCU however the negative side of
that is it looks like we're not going to
see them for another few years so this
most likely puts their debut in the MCU
for New Mutants after Secret Wars which
means phase 7 is most likely going to be
like I've been theorizing for a while
the mutant Saga however that doesn't
mean that we aren't going to see some
new X-Men in the MCU before then because
we are in fact we already have not X-Men
per se not yet but we have seen mutants
obviously Kamala Khan was introduced as
a mutant Miss Marvel which was a change
from the comics but we're going to
assume Marvel has a pretty good plan
there and of course Namor is a mutant
they have blatantly told us that they
even used the word mutant in the movie
and recently at ccxp in Brazil the
Comic-Con experience Kevin feige
attended for the Marvel Studios panel
and he was asked about when the X-Men
would appear now when he was first asked
that he joked around and he said it's
too loud in here I can't hear you it's
so loud what obviously making a joke to
kind of avoid the topic because he
doesn't want to give anything away Kevin
feige is not the spoiler man however he
did end up saying no look we've already
met a few there's a new Mutant named
Namor that you might have met recently
so more to come so this is great news
because that seems like it's a very
clear indication that more mutants new
ones are going to be coming in the MCU
before c Secret Wars but what exactly is
the plan well to talk about the new plan
for Marvel Studios unfortunately we have
to talk about the rights to the X-Men
for those who don't know in the movies
and in the TV shows Fox held the rights
to the X-Men the Fantastic Four and a
few others for a very long time now over
the past few years Disney has gotten
those rights back however recently not
too long ago a new report came out that
stated Marvel Studios doesn't
technically get the rights to the X-Men
back until 2025 and until then they have
to use the old X-Men actors in The Old
X-Men characters if they wanted the
X-Men and the MCU now this is both good
and bad this means that they can
introduce new characters to the MCU but
they can't use the official X-Men team
or any of the old characters like
Professor Xavier Cyclops storm you name
it and based off of what Marvel Studios
has done recently it seems like this is
pretty accurate they had Patrick Stewart
back as Professor X in Multiverse
Madness we have Hugh Jackman returning
as Wolverine and recently Ryan Reynold
has pretty much told us that this rumor
about the contracts is probably true in
a recent interview he was asked about
the complications of bringing Hugh
Jackman to Deadpool 3. and what he said
was kind of eye-opening here's what he
said it's not like adding Hugh Jackman
to a movie like this is a hard sell it's
an immediate and emphatic unqualified
yes it's a lot of moving parts and fox
and X-Men and all that kind of stuff
that Marvel needs to sort through a lot
of red tape in order to make that happen
and they did it and I'm really grateful
that they did it because for me working
with Hugh is a dream come true but
working with Logan and having Logan and
Wade together in a movie is beyond any
dream I would ever be audacious enough
to have so I'm really really super
effing excited to do this film so Ryan
Reynolds has just told us that there was
still a lot of red tape in moving parts
to sort through for the fox and the
X-Men to appear in the MCU but Marvel
made it happen unfortunately this tells
us about this report about the rights
not coming back until 2020 5 is most
likely true but the good news is that
now that we know this we pretty much
know Marvel Studios as plan and even
though we can't get the new X-Men team
in the MCU yet their plan is still
pretty epic have the old X-Men teams
return and in a way it's actually kind
of perfect we get to see the old X-Men
characters and actors in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe they're going to come
together with the characters that we
know and love already The Avengers the
Guardians Spider-Man they're going to be
on screen with Tobey Maguire Spider-Man
with the old Fantastic Four hopefully
we're going to see Tom Holland's
Spider-Man interacting with Deadpool and
Toby Maguire interacting with Captain
America we will have mutants in the MCO
at that point in time and they will be
joining the fight however the official
X-Men team will not have been
established yet that is going to happen
in Phase seven right after we get a huge
send-off to the original X-Men and the
original Fantastic Four from the fox
universes a great send-off to them and
even Grace Randolph reported that that's
what Kevin feige's plan was his final
send-off for those X-Men characters from
the fox universe so in Avengers Secret
Wars we are going to see Worlds Collide
universes Collide and we'll see The
Avengers The Fantastic Four the new and
old Fantastic Four because our new
Fantastic Four team is coming in 2024
and we'll see the old X-Men team will
see some New Mutants as well combined
with our Avengers team and our new
characters going up against Kang the
Conqueror and most likely some evil
variants of themselves so Secret Wars is
going to be absolutely insane and what's
even better is that after Secret Wars
we'll get our new X-Men team they'll
start to build on that so it's not just
going to die down after Secret Wars it's
not going to be a reboot phase like
phase four has been it's going to be the
mutant Saga so lots of really exciting
things coming up from Marvel Studios in
the next handful of years but let me
know how excited you are for this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe to stay up to
date on everything and to enter the
giveaway for live updates you can follow
us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching in woof woof